.
* Träge Gitarrenklänge *
* Möwenkreischen *
Jahrhundertealte Baumriesen:
Das ist der Regenwald von Tongass,
auch Amazonas Nordamerikas genannt.
Über 1'000 Inseln entlang
eines 500 km langen Küstenstreifens
im Südosten Alaskas, kaum besiedelt.
* Träge Gitarrenklänge *
Seit vielen Jahren kommt der schwei-
zerisch-kanadische Bärenforscher
Reno Sommerhalder immer wieder
in diese Abgeschiedenheit.
Der Südosten Alaskas, diese Wälder,
die wunderschönen Regenwälder
sind mir extrem wichtig.
Und dieser Ort hier spezifisch.
Denn hier habe ich vor ca. 35 Jahren
meine ersten Braunbären gesehen.
Ich habe also meine ersten Erfah-
rungen mit diesen Tieren gesammelt,
die mir heute in meinem Leben
so wichtig sind,
als Indikatoren
für eine gesunde Umwelt.
Und so stellt Reno Sommerhalder fest,
dass sich die Wildnis -
die Tier- und Pflanzenwelt -
verändert hat.
Der Klimawandel lässt die Gletscher
auch hier schwinden.
Die lebenswichtigen Lachszüge
sind unregelmässig geworden,
die Bären seltener.
Bei dieser Reise will Sommerhalder
der Wildnis nochmals
besonders nahe kommen.
Und so wagt er den Versuch,
sich die Nahrung - so weit möglich -
aus der Natur zu holen,
wie es auch die Bären tun.
Bislang allerdings
hat noch kein Fisch angebissen.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Nur noch wenige Kreuzfahrtschiffe
legen in diesen Coronazeiten
in Juneau an.
Die zahlreichen Touristenläden
beklagen Umsatzeinbussen,
andere geniessen die Entschleunigung.
Und so scheint das abgelegene
Städtchen in diesem Sommer
noch etwas weiter entrückt.
35'000 Einwohner,
eine kleine Hauptstadt
für einen riesigen Bundesstaat,
Alaska,
in welchem die Schweiz
über 40-mal Platz fände.
Juneau hat keine Strassenverbindung
zur restlichen Welt,
ist nur über die Luft oder das Wasser
erreichbar.
Alle Strassen hier
enden nach wenigen Kilometern.
Der Mendenhall-Gletscher
reicht fast bis vor die Stadt.
Er ist Teil der Juneau Icefields,
wo 38 grössere Gletscher
ihren Ursprung haben.
Auch diesen Eisströmen raubte
der Klimawandel ihre einstige Grösse.
Lachse
sind in den Bach zurückgekehrt.
Eine Schwarzbärenmutter
zeigt ihrem Jungen,
wie man Fische zu Futter macht.
Die Stadt ist der Natur so nah,
dass Bären sich im Schutz
der nächtlichen Dunkelheit
bis in die Vorgärten
der Wohnsiedlungen wagen.
Früh an einem Samstagmorgen
verlässt die Fähre Juneau.
Nur wenige Passagiere reisen mit,
die meisten indigene Tlingit.
Deren Fahrt geht bis zum ersten
Zwischenhalt auf einer Insel,
die von Angehörigen
dieses indigenen Volkes bewohnt wird.
8 Std. dauert die Reise
an den Rand der Zivilisation,
hindurch zwischen Inseln,
die kaum Spuren menschlicher
Anwesenheit erkennen lassen.
Am Ende dieser Fahrt
werden für Reno Sommerhalder
Wochen des Verzichts folgen.
Der Verzicht in den nächsten Wochen,
während ich mich von Bärennahrung
zu ernähren versuche,
wenn ich z.B. an einen guten Kaffee
oder einen Apple Pie denke,
wird schon nicht einfach.
Aber gleichzeitig
ist das auch ein Challenge für mich.
Und sobald ich an einem solchen
sehr naturbelassenen Ort bin,
verschwinden normalerweise
die zivilisierten Gelüste
nach solchen Dingen.
Solche Reisen sind für mich
darum extrem wichtig.
Da sieht man,
wie wenig man eigentlich braucht,
um gesund und glücklich zu sein
im Leben.
Dann kommt der kleine Inselort
in Sicht:
Häuser auf Stelzen,
ein Dörflein, von dem
der Bürgermeister gebeten hat,
den Namen nicht zu nennen.
Hier möchte man von der Welt-
öffentlichkeit unentdeckt bleiben,
besonders von der Strömen
des Massentourismus.
Wegen des vielen Gepäcks
lässt sich Reno Sommerhalder
mit dem Boot
zum Ziel der Reise fahren,
einige Kilometer
ausserhalb des Dorfes.
* Träge Gitarrenklänge *
Das einsame Haus
soll Ausgangspunkt werden
für Renos Streifzüge in die Wildnis,
für seine Suche nach Nahrung.
Sogleich nach seiner Ankunft
zieht es ihn an den Indian River
unweit der Hütte,
eigentlich ein Lachsfluss.
Doch bei seinen Besuchen
in den letzten Jahren
hatte er hier
kaum mehr Lachse gefunden.
Nun diese erfreuliche Überraschung:
Es ist Mitte August, und der Fluss
ist voller Buckellachse.
Und das lässt Reno
auch auf Bären hoffen.
Bären, die sich
an den Lachsen gütlich tun.
Das ist ein junges Männchen.
Es scheint heute seinen Appetit
auf Lachse bereits gestillt zu haben.
Die Jagd ist bloss mehr ein Spiel,
für die Fische
allerdings ein tödliches.
* Träge Gitarrenklänge *
Um sich ernähren zu können,
muss Reno Fische fangen.
Fische, besonders Lachse,
sollen seine Hauptnahrung sein
in den nächsten Wochen.
Auch ein Nerz
sucht am Ufer nach Futter.
Renos Bemühungen sind vergebens.
Ein Fischotter ist erfolgreicher.
Doch das seichte Wasser
bietet auch andere Köstlichkeiten.
Diese Scheren können einem schon
etwas abzwacken, die sind stark.
Darum sollte man sie so packen.
Ich würde sagen, die nehmen wir.
Eintauchen in den Tongass,
in diesen magischen Regenwald,
der gleich hinter der Hütte beginnt.
Es ist der grösste Nationalforst
der Vereinigten Staaten,
eineinhalbmal so gross
wie die Schweiz.
* Sanfte, sphärische Klänge *
* Vogelrufe *
* Krächzen *
* Helles Vogelzetern *
* Sanfte, sphärische Klänge *
Hier ging ein Bär vorbei.
Hier haben wir
diesen wunderschönen Pilz.
Auf Englisch nennen sie den chicken
of the woods oder sulphur shelf.
Ich kenne den deutschen Namen nicht.
Aber es ist ein wunderbarer Esspilz.
Reno Sommerhalder, in der Schweiz
geboren und aufgewachsen,
lebt heute mit seiner Familie
im kanadischen Banff,
wo er als Bärenexperte,
als Wildnis-Guide
und Vortragsreisender
seinen Lebensunterhalt verdient.
Bevor er sich ganz den Bären
und ihrer Welt zuwandte,
hatte er eine Lehre als Koch gemacht.
Das kommt ihm nun gelegen.
* Vogelrufe *
* Sanfte, nachdenkliche Klänge *
Fast täglich zieht es Reno zum nahen
Indian River, zum Lachsfluss.
In gewaltigen Schwärmen
sind die Buckellachse aus den Ozeanen
zurückgekehrt an ihren Ursprung,
hierher, wo sie vor zwei Jahren
geschlüpft sind.
Nun sind sie geschlechtsreif, bereit
zu laichen und dann zu sterben.
Mit dem Wechsel
vom Salz- ins Süsswasser
ist den Männchen
ein grosser Buckel gewachsen,
der Kopf
hat sich hakenförmig verbogen.
Und damit hat auch
der körperliche Zerfall begonnen.
Ein Weibchen schaufelt mit dem
Schwanz eine Mulde für die Eiablage.
Möwen tauchen
nach abgeschwemmten Lachseiern.
Andere scharren danach.
Und besonders mögen die Vögel
die Augen der toten Lachse.
Reno beschliesst,
flussaufwärts zu waten.
Er sucht eine Stelle zum Fischen.
Und mindestens ebenso hofft er,
Bären am Lachsfluss zu treffen.
Am gegenüberliegenden Ufer
erblickt er ein junges Tier,
abgemagert und ungelenk,
es scheint krank zu sein.
* Träge Gitarrenklänge *
Dieser Bär
hat den Menschen nicht bemerkt,
kommt über den Fluss
direkt auf Reno zu.
Hi.
It's okay. It's okay.
It's okay.
Good bear.
Ein erneuter Versuch,
an Nahrung, an Fische zu kommen.
Doch nicht nach Buckellachsen
wirft Reno seine Angel aus.
Deren Fleisch
ist in diesem Endstadium ausgezehrt
und wenig schmackhaft.
Aber es gehen auch
keine anderen Fische an die Angel.
Es bleibt ein weiterer,
glückloser Versuch.
Reno Sommerhalder
wird seine Fangmethode ändern müssen.
Ein Bekannter aus dem Dorf
hat sich bereiterklärt,
Reno mit seinem Boot zum Fischfang
auf den Meeresarm hinauszufahren.
* Summen des Bootsmotors *
* Lautes Schnauben *
Zwei Buckelwale kreuzen den Weg,
nur wenige Meter entfernt.
* Bewegte Gitarrenmelodie *
Das Boot hält auf eine Stelle zu,
wo der kleine Meeresarm
auf einen grösseren trifft.
Dort gibt es mehr Strömung,
mehr Futter für Fische.
Das Glück des Fischers
hängt auch davon ab,
mit dem Köder die richtige Tiefe
zu erwischen,
jene Wassertiefe, in der sich
die gesuchten Lachse aufhalten.
* Rattern der Seilwinde *
Ja, da ist einer dran.
* Unverständliches Gespräch *
Nach dem Fang wird der Silberlachs
für einige Minuten im Meerwasser
gewässert, um das Blut auszuwaschen.
Und das Fischerglück hält an.
Wow, beautiful.
* Nachdenkliche Melodie *
Nach vier gefangenen Silberlachsen
schliesslich noch ein
ganz dicker Fisch, ein Königslachs.
Die Nahrung für Reno ist
für die nächsten 15 Tage gesichert:
Fünf Lachse liegen in der Kühlbox.
Die Lachsstücke werden in eine Mari-
nade aus Zucker und Salz eingelegt.
Es ist der Anfang
einer aufwendigen Arbeit,
um den Fisch haltbar zu machen,
auch ohne Kühlschrank.
* Schlagen *
Eine junge Erle soll das Holz
und v.a. das Laub liefern
für das Räuchern am nächsten Tag.
* Plätschern *
Es ist mittlerweile Nacht geworden.
Nach 5 Std. in der Marinade
erhalten die Lachsstücke ein Bad:
Die Zucker- und Salzrückstände
werden ausgewaschen.
* Regenprasseln *
Der letzte Teil der Prozedur -
das Räuchern -
verlangt
besonders viel Aufmerksamkeit.
Zuerst ein Feuer,
um eine Glut zu erzeugen.
Darauf packt Reno
die grünen Erlenzweige.
Die Kunst liegt nun darin, genügend
Hitze unter dem Fisch zu haben,
ohne dass die Flammen
zu lodern beginnen
und die Lachsstücke
dadurch verbrennen.
7 Std. muss der mottende Schwelbrand
im Räucherofen im Blickfeld bleiben.
Ich fürchte immer, dass es durch
den Erlen-Rauch etwas bitter wird.
Aber es ist super gelungen.
Eine gute Kombination
aus leichter Süsse und Salz.
Konserviert.
Ich hoffe, das hält für zwei Wochen.
Knapp 1 Std. dauert der Fussmarsch
durch den Wald ins Dorf.
* Krächzen *
Alle paar Meter
liegt ein Bärenkothaufen.
Die wenigsten Dorfbewohner würden
diesen Weg gehen - wegen der Bären.
Obschon keine Bärenattacken
aus der Gegend bekannt sind.
Ich bin seit 35 Jahren
in den dichtesten Bärenpopulationen
der Welt unterwegs.
Ich hatte noch nie
eine Flinte dabei.
Ich kann an einer Hand abzählen,
wie viele Begegnungen nicht
so verliefen, wie ich gewollt hätte.
Aber auch diese
waren problemlos abwendbar.
Und für einen solchen
unwahrscheinlichen Notfall
trägt Reno stets
einen Bären-Pfefferspray mit sich.
Ein Bär will eigentlich
nichts anderes als wir Menschen:
seinen Frieden.
Bären wollen sich ernähren können
und zwar friedlich.
Auch Kämpfe unter Bären
sind aus diesem Grund sehr selten.
Ich verstehe also diese Angst nicht.
Die Angst vor dem Bären
ist irrational.
Sie ist auf ein falsches Bild
zurückzuführen,
das der Mensch vor Hunderten Jahren
etabliert hat.
In vielen Regionen
ausserhalb geschützter Gegenden
besteht dieses Angstbild noch heute.
Es ist ähnlich wie mit dem Wolf
bei "Rotkäppchen".
Da wird ein Wolf porträtiert,
der so in der realen Welt
hinten und vorne nicht vorkommt.
Das kleine Dorf am Rande der Wildnis.
Noch knapp 100 Menschen leben hier,
im Winter etwa halb so viele.
Die meisten sind nicht hier geboren,
sie sind angezogen worden
von den besonderen Lebensumständen:
Ruhe, Einfachheit, Natur.
Es gibt kein Restaurant, keinen
Polizisten und kein Mobilfunknetz.
Das einzige Hotel steht zum Verkauf.
Den Leuten hier ist es recht,
wenn ihr Dasein
von der übrigen Welt übersehen wird.
Kreuzfahrtschiffen wurde erfolgreich
das Anlegen verwehrt.
Zweimal im Monat
kommt die Fähre aus der Hauptstadt.
Und immerhin zweimal täglich
landet ein Wasserflugzeug,
wenn es das Wetter zulässt,
bringt Pakete und Passagiere.
Der einzige Laden
mit bescheidenem Angebot,
wo Reno einkauft,
was er nicht in der Wildnis findet.
Das Haus von Dan Kennedy,
Bürgermeister dieses Ortes.
Seit 34 Jahren wohnt er hier.
Der Klimawandel bereitet ihm Sorgen.
In meinem ersten Winter hier
war es -31 °C kalt.
Es lag monatelang 1,5 m Schnee.
Und die Sommer waren wärmer,
weniger feucht.
Wir hatten noch vier Jahreszeiten.
Nun scheint es während 90 % des
Jahres so zu sein wie gerade jetzt:
nass und kühl.
Es gibt
keine richtig kalten Winter mehr.
Der Fischbestand hat sich verändert,
ebenso die Flora.
Renos Besuch im Dorf endet
im kleinen, öffentlichen Thermalbad.
Ein Urwaldfriedhof.
Vor 50 Jahren wurde der Regenwald
hier zerstört.
Grossflächige Kahlschläge finden sich
v.a. in Ufernähe und an Flüssen.
Seither ist ein Sekundärwald
nachgewachsen,
biologisch von geringerem Wert.
Eine kleine Sägerei.
Sie liefert Bauholz für die Menschen
in der nahen Umgebung,
Holz, das sonst von weit her
aus dem Süden, v.a. aus Kalifornien
importiert werden muss.
Sterling Chew
heisst der junge Besitzer.
Er will das Holzgeschäft
zu einer nachhaltigen, verant-
wortungsvollen Tätigkeit machen.
Handwerk statt Industrie.
Der grosse Unterschied ist:
Wenn ein Mann mit der Säge arbeitet,
dann limitiert dies
die Menge des Holzschlags.
Beim industriellen,
mechanisierten Holzschlag hingegen
werden täglich 1'600 Bäume gefällt.
Die Handarbeit im Wald hat weniger
Auswirkungen, ist selektiver.
Und diese Arbeit macht Spass.
Ich hoffe, dass wir noch lange
mit der Säge arbeiten können.
Sterling Chew schont die wertvollen,
mehrere Hundert Jahre alten
Urwaldriesen.
Solche würde er hier, im Gebiet
eines einstigen Kahlschlags,
auch keine finden.
Jüngere Bäume aus einem Sekundärwuchs
sucht er sich aus.
Doch auch dieses Fichtenholz
ist von einigem kommerziellen Wert.
Das Holz der Sitka-Fichte
gilt als das leichteste
und stärkste des Planeten.
Es wird gebraucht
für den Flugzeugbau, für Gitarren.
Und einige der schnellsten Segel-
boote sind aus Sitka-Fichte gebaut.
Denn das Holz
ist so leicht und stark,
dass es sogar
mit Karbonfaser mithalten kann.
* Lautes Knacken *
* Träge Gitarrenklänge *
Der Tongass-Regenwald, ein weitgehend
geschützter National Forest,
immerhin zu 70 % noch Urwald,
als Ökosystem von unschätzbarem Wert.
Auch für das Klima, allein schon
wegen der gewaltigen Menge CO2,
die in den Bäumen und v.a. im Boden
gespeichert wird.
Mitten im Regenwald
lebt der Schriftsteller Kim Heacox,
Autor mehrerer Bücher
über die Wildnis Alaskas.
Der Tongass-Regenwald
ist deshalb wichtig,
weil er sozusagen
die Lunge Nordamerikas ist.
Pro Quadratkilometer hat er wohl
weltweit die grösste Menge Biomasse,
also lebende Stoffe.
Es gibt keinen anderen Ort
wie diesen.
Und doch ist diese Wildnis
immer wieder bedroht.
US-Präsident Donald Trump
hat in seinen letzten Amtstagen
den grossflächigen Holzschlag
und den Bau neuer Strassen
im geschützten Tongass bewilligt.
Sein Nachfolger Joe Biden
hat das Vorhaben wieder gestoppt.
Dem Tongass
drohen die gleichen Gefahren,
die Nordamerika
seit 500 Jahren bedrohten.
Es ist das räuberische Verlangen,
alles ändern zu wollen -
etwa die Bäume zu fällen -
in der Meinung,
sie würden so mehr einbringen.
Der Tongass
leistet für uns eine grosse Arbeit,
einfach,
wenn wir ihn so lassen, wie er ist.
* Krächzen *
Die Hütte am Waldrand, ein Ort,
an den Reno immer wieder zurückkehrt,
seit 35 Jahren schon.
Eine letzte Station
zwischen Zivilisation und Wildnis.
Ein bescheidenes Häuschen
ohne fliessendes Wasser.
Dieses wird aus dem Bach
hinter dem Gebäude geholt.
Der Kühlschrank.
Immerhin, beim Kochen hilft Gas.
Und das Plumpsklo
bietet nicht nur Doppelsitze,
sondern auch viel frische Luft.
Doch der wahre Luxus ist der
grossartige Blick aus dem Fenster,
hin zum Wasser.
Ein nie endendes Spektakel der Natur,
ganz ohne menschliche Beteiligung.
* Sanfte, sphärische Klänge *
Es ist aber auch ein Ort
der stillen Tragödien.
Gleich hinter der Hütte entdeckt Reno
Sommerhalder ein totes Bärenjunges.
* Fliegensummen *
Über 50 % der Jungbären sterben
normalerweise im ersten Jahr.
Aus verschiedenen Gründen:
Es kann sein, dass sie
nicht genügend Nahrung finden,
es kann Konflikte zwischen
der Mutter und einem anderen Bären,
möglicherweise einem Männchen,
geben.
Es kommt sogar vor, dass Jungbären
von Adlern geschnappt werden.
Es gibt verschiedene Gründe dafür,
dass ein Jungbär umkommt.
Buckelwale vor der Hütte.
Im Verband jagen sie kreisförmig
von unten einen Fischschwarm.
* Aufgeregtes Kreischen *
Reno trifft die Walforscherin
Heidi Pearson.
In Südostalaska seien die Bestände
der Buckelwale zwar stabil, sagt sie.
Doch sie erwähnt
zahlreiche Bedrohungen.
Buckelwale sehen sich
vielen Gefahren ausgesetzt.
Da ist der Klimawandel, der einen
Einfluss auf die Beutetiere hat,
was sich auf die Gesundheit der Wale
auswirken kann.
Da ist die Gefahr, sich in den
Leinen der Fischer zu verheddern.
Dies kann zu Verletzungen
und gar zum Tode führen.
Es gibt auch die Gefahr,
mit Schiffen zu kollidieren.
Wir haben solche Fälle dokumentiert,
in denen Wale durch eine Kollision
mit einem Schiff zu Tode kamen.
Es war im November 2020.
Die Walretter waren alarmiert worden,
Gordon Chew
leitete die Rettungsaktion.
Die Schreie eines Buckelwals hatten
Dorfbewohner aus dem Schlaf gerissen.
* Bedrohliche Klänge *
Es war sehr verstörend,
ein solch grosses Tier
in diesem Stress zu hören,
einige hundert Meter
von deinem Haus entfernt.
Eine über 100 kg schwere Krabbenfalle
hing wie ein Anker
an der Schwanzflosse.
Der Wal hatte diese Last
von Kodiak hergeschleppt,
1'000 km durch den Golf von Alaska.
Nun war er zusammengeschnürt,
fast bewegungsunfähig, nahe dem Tod.
* Lautes Schnauben *
Zuerst mussten die Walretter
versuchen,
das Tier vom schweren Gewicht
am Schwanz zu befreien.
Dann begann sich das Tier
wieder langsam zu bewegen.
Es wurde nun für uns
viel schwieriger und gefährlicher.
Wir brauchten etwa 30 Versuche,
bis die anderen Leinen
zerschnitten waren.
Dann schwamm das Tier davon.
Acht Monate nach dieser Rettung,
im Juli 2021,
wurde der Wal erstmals
wieder gesehen, 150 km entfernt,
befreit auch
von den restlichen Seilen.
Er hat überlebt.
Das Wasserflugzeug nimmt Kurs
auf Angoon, eine Nachbarinsel,
die fast ausschliesslich
von Tlingit bewohnt wird.
Totempfähle - Erinnerungen
an eine verblasste, reiche Kultur.
Kootznahoo - dies der Name der Insel
in der Tlingit-Sprache.
Eine Lehrerin bringt ihren Schülern
die Verarbeitung von Lachs bei.
Einst traditionelles Tageswerk,
welches das Überleben sicherte.
Früher lebten hier 800 Menschen,
heute sind es noch gut 300.
Auf der Insel
herrscht ein Alkoholverkaufsverbot.
Alkohol ist ein grosses Problem.
Zahlreiche Häuser sind baufällig.
Die Tlingit wurden
durch das Eindringen der Weissen
ihrer Wurzeln beraubt.
Doch richtig angekommen sind sie
in der neuen,
materialistischen Welt nicht.
Ein kulturelles Trauma.
Ken Johnson ist Selbstversorger,
Fischer und Jäger.
Wann hast du diese Fische gefangen?
- Gestern.
Zu Besuch sind Alan Zuboff
und Frank Jim, zwei Häuptlinge.
Ihre Tlingit-Namen zu nennen,
sei sinnlos, sagen sie,
denn die Weissen könnten diese
ohnehin nicht aussprechen.
Ken Johnson hat im Wald
diese Bärenfalle gefunden.
Jagst du auch Bären?
Nein, das bringt mir nur Unglück.
Ich störe sie nicht,
und sie stören mich nicht.
Meine Grossmutter sagte immer,
die Bären seien wie Menschen.
Sie essen die gleichen Beeren
wie wir, sie essen Fische wie wir,
sie essen Fleisch wie wir.
Den Fortschritt, den die Weissen
auch auf diese Insel brachten,
betrachtet der Tlingit-Häuptling
mit Bitterkeit.
Die kommerzielle Fischerei hat
unsere Heringbestände vernichtet.
Ein einziges Schiff.
Seit 300 Jahren gibt es hier
diese kommerzielle Wirtschaft.
In dieser Zeit
hat sie viel zerstört.
Und das soll der Fortschritt sein?
Dieses Wort passt doch nicht,
angesichts dieser Zerstörung.
Die beiden Tlingit Chiefs
wollen Reno etwas zeigen.
Unterhalb der kleinen Kirche
sind zahlreiche weisse Kreuze
über einen Abhang verteilt.
Vor einigen Jahren ist man hier
auf ein Massengrab gestossen.
Und man fand über 300 Gräber.
V.a. Frauen und Kinder,
hingerafft vor rund 160 Jahren
durch das Pockenvirus. Ein Mit-
bringsel der weissen Eindringlinge,
das, wie geschätzt wird,
fast die Hälfte der Ureinwohner
an der Pazifikküste auslöschte.
* Sanfte, sphärische Klänge *
Nahrungssuche am Ufer,
im Licht der ersten Sonnenstrahlen.
Eine Seegurke zuzubereiten, verlangt
Kenntnisse über die essbaren Teile.
Schmeckt wie Tintenfisch.
Seegurke mit Rüebli,
dazu geräuchter Lachs.
* Träge Gitarrenklänge *
Der Regen hat den Indian River
braun gefärbt.
Am Oberlauf des Baches,
bei den kleinen Wasserfällen
stauen sich die Lachse.
Es sind nicht mehr Buckellachse,
sondern Silberlachse,
grösser und stärker.
Sie drängen nach weiter oben,
über die Wasserfälle hinaus.
Reno versucht, einen
der fliegenden Fische zu fangen.
Sieht einfach aus,
doch erweist sich als verzwickt.
Wie auch die Anstrengungen
der Lachse, nach oben zu kommen.
Ein Boot bringt Reno
auf die andere Seite des Meeresarmes,
in eine menschenleere Landschaft.
Es ist ein Schritt
ganz hinein in die Wildnis.
Wer hier übernachten will,
benötigt ein Zelt.
Ein elektrischer Zaun soll
allzu neugierige Bären fernhalten.
Es ist bereits später Nachmittag.
Noch vor dem Eindunkeln
erkundet Reno die Umgebung.
Frische Bärenspuren
wirken wie ein Versprechen.
Das sich dann
auch wenig später erfüllt.
Es wird allerdings nur
eine enttäuschend kurze Begegnung.
Der Bär, offenbar sehr menschenscheu,
verschwindet bald im Grün.
Geräucherter Lachs zum Abendessen.
Eine Wasseramsel sucht
unter den Blättern nach Fressbarem.
* Vereinzeltes Vogelzetern *
* Gänsequaken *
Am nächsten Morgen
ein erneuter Versuch,
die vielen Bären wieder zu sehen,
die er bei seiner früheren Besuchen
vorfand.
Doch selbst ein längerer Marsch
flussaufwärts
verschafft keine
der erhofften Begegnungen.
* Eindringliche Melodie *
Immerhin ist da
ein anderes Erfolgserlebnis -
in der Nachbarschaft
der Fliegenpilze.
Steinpilze,
gleich eine ganze Ansammlung.
Hinter mir ist ein Bärenbett unter
einer wunderschönen Sitka spruce.
Und 1 m davon entfernt
finde ich nochmals vier,
fünf wunderschöne Steinpilze.
Bären sind sehr sauber.
Sie hinterlassen keinen Kot
in ihrem eigenen Bett,
sondern bewegen sich
rückwärts aus ihrem Bett hinaus
und machen ihr Geschäft dort.
Und hier, wo die Steinpilze sind,
haben sie möglicherweise
den Boden gedüngt
und so einen Garten gesät.
Eine Idylle,
die in diesen Spätsommertagen
zum Ort des massenhaften Sterbens
wird.
Der stille Tod, nur vom Plätschern
begleitet, sieht grausam aus.
Aber als Teil des grossen Ganzen
erhält die Tragödie
eine Sinnhaftigkeit.
Nur wenige Lebewesen
führen den Kreislauf des Lebens
so drastisch vor Augen
wie die Lachse.
* Sanfte, sphärische Melodie *
Für Reno war der Abstecher in diesen
besonders entlegenen Teil der Insel
eine Enttäuschung.
Ich hatte mehr Bären erwartet,
obwohl wir einige gesehen haben.
Ich erwartete mehr.
Aber irgendwie ergibt das auch Sinn.
Denn die Bären
werden leider intensiv bejagt.
Die Bären hier haben gelernt,
dass Menschen
lebensgefährlich sein können.
* Krächzen *
Stürmische Winde
kündigen den Herbst an.
* Leises Heulen *
Die Farben der Natur ändern sich.
* Vogellaute *
Die Suche nach Nahrung
führt Reno in den Wald.
Die Beeren sind reif. Und das Angebot
scheint unerschöpflich.
* Sanfte, perlende Gitarrenmelodie *
* Mehrmaliges Pusten *
Die Ufer des Indian River sind mitt-
lerweile von toten Fischen übersät.
Und doch sind die Lachszüge
noch immer nicht erschöpft.
Bären allerdings
sind kaum mehr am Wasser anzutreffen.
Wo sie sind, verrät ein Kothaufen.
Bei einem Gang ins Dorf
entdeckt Reno unweit der Siedlung
einen Bären in den Beerensträuchern.
Lachsfluss oder Beerenwald - dies ist
für die Bären zum Dilemma geworden.
Die Lachszüge erreichen die Flüsse
vier bis sechs Wochen später
als in früheren Jahren.
Vermutlich
eine Folge des Klimawandels.
Die Lachsvorkommen kollidieren
deshalb zeitlich mit der Beerenreife.
Und so wird das Zeitfenster
für die Bären kürzer,
sich die notwendigen Fettreserven
für die Winterruhe anzufressen.
Für die Gesundheit der Pelztiere
sind das keine guten Umstände.
Noch einmal streift Reno auf seiner
Nahrungssuche durch die Wildnis.
Diese Pflanze
versteckt im Boden Nahrhaftes.
Das ist eine Lilienart, auf Englisch
heisst sie chocolate lily
oder northern rice-root.
Auch Bären graben sie in verschie-
denen Regionen Nordamerikas aus.
Sie enthalten sehr viele Kohle-
hydrate, ähnlich wie eine Kartoffel.
Die gibt es heute zum Abendessen.
Mitte September,
es ist eine der letzten Mahlzeiten,
die Reno hier zubereitet.
Es soll ein Festessen werden.
Die Knollen der Schokoladenlilie
mit gebratenem Lachs,
dazu ein Pilzragout.
Ich komme seit 35 Jahren
an diesen Fluss.
Die Lachse sind immer noch hier, sie
kommen aber nicht mehr regelmässig.
Der Hundelachs
ist fast gar nicht mehr hier.
Beim Buckellachs
ist es sehr wechselhaft.
Dieses Jahr gab es einige mehr,
in vergangenen Jahren
gab es sehr wenige.
Der Klimawandel hat dieses System
auch extrem beeinflusst.
2018, 2019 gab es z.T. praktisch
kein Wasser mehr in diesem Fluss.
Diese Fische
sind ja der Leim dieser Ökosysteme,
sie halten alles zusammen.
Sie füttern alles -
an Land und im Wasser.
Begegnungen mit Bären
gab es wenige in diesem Sommer.
Anders als in früheren Jahren.
Ich habe in diesem ersten Abschnitt
des Flusses
regelmässig zwischen acht
und 14 Bären pro Tag gesehen.
Die ganze Struktur
dieser Bärenpopulation war gesund.
Mütter mit Jungbären,
ältere und jüngere Bären,
Männchen und Weibchen.
Dieses Jahr haben wir
drei bis vier Bären gesehen.
Alle waren juvenil, also subadult.
Und alle waren Männchen.
Das ist doch ein starker Indikator
dafür, dass es der Bärenpopulation
hier in diesem System
nicht sehr gut geht.
* Erhabene, andächtige Klänge *
* Möwenkreischen *
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
Regina Kolb - 2022